Maya I see everything that you are so
alaa I watched your show Echo I'm a huge
fan the show follows your character Maya
Lopez on her journey as she returns to
her hometown with a plan to take claim
to the infamous kingpin's
Throne there's a really strong spiritual
connection the CH to
people
[Applause]
I love the message of trying to humanize
even the people that we believe are the
worst of the
[Music]
worst what do you think you most love
about
Maya
how important do you think it is to have
that representation of a deaf indigenous
strong woman on
camera there's a moment where you say we
have to get rid of the King Pen it's
time for a
queen
[Music]